こんにちは はじめしゃちょーです
みなさん今までYouTuberとか
僕も含めてなんですけど
様々な人が宙に浮きたいというか
まぁあれでしょ突っ張り棒とかもそうだった
こう、部屋で一定の固定で一定の高さで
こう維持したいという傾向がこう、YouTuberにはなぜかとても多いという傾向がみられる
気がしております
まだほとんどの実験は失敗
突っ張り棒でも無理ということが分かってきましたし
なぁ、ガムテープで天井にくっつこうとしている輩もいました
様々なYouTuberがいる中で私も確実に今回は
今回は本当にあんぱいをとって
ほぼ確実に天井にくっついて
あわよくばなんか筋トレとかもしてしまおうかなと思っております
今回はこちら”SINGLE SUCTION LIFTER”
これ見おぼえないでしょうか
日本語で言うと
逆だった
いわゆる、バキュームカップというものです
これどんな時に使うかといいますと
車とかがぶつかったりし、へこんだ時に
バキュームで空気を吸って取れなくなって
車のへこみがポッて治るっていう
それくらい強力な代物です
わーやべ、ガチもんだなこれ
うぉ～
これですよこれ
これが世にいうバキュームカップ
どうやって使うんだろう
ちゃんと説明書読もう
ハンドルなんてどこにもないよ
こういうところにもくっつけられるのかな？
たぶん、車につけれるということはこういうところにもつけれるということなのでは
よくわかんねぇや
弟よ、バキュームカップのつけかたがわからない
説明書が英語なんだよ
浮くから今日は家の中で
あ、やばいやばい、まって！
やばいやばい
取れなくなっちゃったｗ
弟「ガラスとかやばいって」
そういうことね
もうわかりました。行きますよこれ
もうハンドル完全に
これバコッてつけた後に
とるときにこのハンドルをクイってやると
空気が抜けるみたいです
ではいこう
問題はこれが天井にくっつくがどうかですね
これでくっつかないと本当にもう終わりですから
まじか
待って今完全にバキっていった
ちょ天井微妙なのでちょ、別の場所に行ってみましょう
わぁやばい
絶対天井落ちてくる
さすがに家を壊すわけにはいかないのでなんかこういい場所がないかと思ったんですけども
扉ならくっつけられるのではないかと思っております
あぁ～いいね
いいよ　いいんじゃない？
やばい完璧
見て、完璧にもうこれ完全に取れないです
まじで取れないから一回やってみ？
いやいやいやまさか
はいというわけで家のいろいろなところを探したのですけども
私は気づいてしまった
俺の家でできる場所はない
天井は微妙にぽつぽつしているので、バキュームがこう天井にくっつく場所がない
横にやってもずれるんだよね？
ちゃんとこう上につけてやらないとこう落ちてきちゃうから
失敗することは僕もこうわかったので
家の中でこう何とかしてつるつるの天井を作り出します
そこで使うのがこちら
もうここしかないっしょ
この間を開いてこの間にテーブルをかけて
つけて、俺はこのまま懸垂する
perfect human
この間に机をこう挟みます
悪くない
悪くないけど、これ頭に落ちたら死ぬよ
弟：もうちょいこっちだよ
こう？
あばじゃ
弟：そんな重いん？
もってみ？！
あ、重たい
ちょっと距離縮めたのでこれで置いてみます
ついにこの時が来た
ちょっと今痛かったんだけど
痛いから
弟：アホやん
ついにこの時が来た
いろんなYouTuberが繰り返し挑んできた
室内で浮くこんなにいともたやすく成功させるのは初めてではないだろうか
じゃ、いくぜ
いきます
おら
どうよ、ほら
ね、浮いてない？どう？どう？
どう？？
待って待って、アホ